The Joe Rogan Experience that's the
thing you have to do with SNL right you
have to constantly be coming up with
ideas for sketches huh yeah a lot of
people don't get how
um I think mentally frustrating are not
frustrating mentally uh exhausted yeah I
get exhausted
with SNL live now
asked me to write a pilot I'll write you
a pilot
I'll have fun with it but a sketch is a
different world
it's a different world it's a different
ball game it's not my world
it's it's so you know SNL is a very hard
job very hard job it's not it's I mean
it's hard mentally it's hard physically
it's hard
it man it's hard no no let me tell you
something the perks are great I have a
whole bunch of fun I'm sure I have fun
with those people in there I have to
have fun creating relationships I have
fun you're also a part of a group that
includes
Eddie Murphy yeah John Belushi Kilda
Radner Dan Aykroyd
Phil Hartman that feels good holy [__] I
mean that that's a crazy Legacy Chris
Rock I walk through that building
like it's the palm trees every day yeah
every wild every day I'm like what the
[__] are you
Wild still am I 30 how do you write do
you write in front of a computer do you
write you just sit around and write
things down when they come to you what
do you do well it's a very fast right
the turnover over there is fast so it's
like
you do the show Saturday Sunday you can
rest your mind if you want to but you
got to have something cooking and
boiling inside of your brain about
Sunday night
so then Monday we go we pitch we meet
the hosts and then we pitch ideas what's
a Sunday for you like sleep sleep sleep
sleep no liquor I eat whatever I want
and I sleep all day but do you is that
when you're like prepping do you get
ready for Monday
um sometimes it depends if I have the
strength I'll call people and say hey
you know what you got this week I got
this idea let's figure out how to flush
it out tomorrow which is a Monday right
so Mondays we go to work
uh just to meet the host and kind of
just settle in we meet hello how you
doing like if it was you hey Lauren to
say Joe Rogan everybody we'll all go in
his office his office is about this big
maybe a little smaller and we all sit on
the floor like preschoolers we got our
legs crossed and learn to say we're
gonna start with you Rosebud Rose by the
pitches her idea to you how you doing
Joe she'll say something uh you are a
man that has a vision of exotic coffee
shops so you open up a coffee shop
that's full of strippers and you call it
tease search or some [__] like just just
something stupid it could be a real idea
uh it could be something fake
I always pitch something stupid
look I remember we went to work on black
history
um day I'm on Martin Luther King Day
and my pitch was hey Aubry you are the
uh captain of the holiday police
department and you come and find Lauren
Michaels for having all the black people
at work on Martin Luther King Day the
office was busting out laughing because
I go in there I say what what everybody
want to say because I don't give a [__]
you know what I'm saying I just be
having fun and then after that you leave
the pitch and you go you can either stay
and talk talk and groups and figure out
what you're going to do for Tuesday or
you leave I leave or I stay blah blah
and then Tuesday you write all day
we get to the office two three o'clock
we don't leave till two three o'clock
and then Wednesdays you got to wake up
at eight go over your sketches with your
writers fix it
maybe you'll go back to sleep about 10
30 11 sleep for 30 minutes get back up
go to work until 11 pm 12 P.M if your
sketch get picked you know because you
got to produce it so Rob also at this
job I'm learning how to produce
learning how to direct
learning how to make fast edits
um because you got to pick your set
you got to pick the clothes that people
are going to wear you got to pick the
outfits you got to pick the wigs you
gotta if you write the sketch and they
get picked you got to do it all
of course you have help
but
you're learning the stuff did you do any
of that before you went to SNL no no
theater no nothing I went to an active
school called the Actis boot camp but
that was that that's neither here nor
there yeah well I think acting class is
probably in some ways a little bit like
um comedy class you know I think there's
good ones in terms of acting class
there's legitimate like real good places
where people learn they really do and
then there's also like acting lessons
that are given by people that weren't
really good actors yeah didn't really
make it as an actor and now you're
teaching it I know a lot of people
that'll teach you something because
they've done it and they that's the
problem with comedy right like the
comedy classes they're not being taught
by Dave Chappelle right you know they're
being taught by someone who's probably
not that good at comedy which is why
they're teaching classes yeah that's
true there's a lot of that but it
doesn't keep you on stage though that's
the benefit of it I um when I did get to
SNL a lot of people did go to school
they did they went to action school they
went to like improv School Second City
ground links and all of that because the
moment I get to know people over there
I'm like oh y'all went to school
yeah oh
I came from a little place with black
walls called The Comedy Store I don't
know nothing about this this type of
school though
you know it's a type of performance
school for sure that's what I'm saying
so I'm just and and with that then
that's me saying to myself what are you
doing